take one step back because I'll be
honest
you know we're dealing with doubts and
we're dealing with atheism and we're
dealing with the skeptic mind of course
people are going to say well actually I
don't believe in all this stuff sorry to
say Yeah in fact some of them they say
I remember walking home from school one
time and a person who was supposedly
Muslim yeah
I'm not going to reveal his name
but he came he said to me you know
because I used to go to the prayer rooms
and these kind of things he said to me
do you really believe in these things
this is what he said
and this was by the way this was the
time where I think new atheism was at
his height like Richard Dawkins and
these guys there he looked at me and
then he started laughing he's like I
said do you really believe in these
things
I said I was I was surprised that he had
that like mentality but believe me this
mentality is widespread
in the Muslim world and this is
widespread obviously in the world itself
what are we talking about here the high
beat Heaven hell the Angels the wings
you say 600 Rings the handwriver officer
what are you talking about I'm into
science I'm into materialism
ah
I think he was ironically burned uh
Russell The Atheist famous
who said and it might not have been him
but yeah and he might have said this it
might have been him he said today's
technology was is yesterday's Magic
yeah let me let's just put something in
perspective first let me make a claim
and then I want to back out my claim is
as follows let me put a second
my claim is
that it's the easiest time in history to
believe in the hybrid
that's my claim Yani Heaven held the
Angels it is the easiest time to believe
in it now than any other time in history
why if I took this phone a thousand four
hundred years ago when the prophet
sallam was around we talked about
already we were outside we saw the jubel
we saw the mountains we saw all this
stuff yeah we saw all of that and I
imagine taking away the buildings and
taking away everything taking away the
electronics in the cars and the people
you only got 10 000 people
and I somehow go into a time machine
and I take this phone with me okay
and I start showing them YouTube videos
of hands resources and this one and that
one and John Fontaine
and this one
what do you think that people are gonna
think I am
no doubt they'll say this guy's a
magician
I does anyone have a doubt about that
imagine if I start to yeah I need to
show them certain other technological
advancements that we have of today
like for example I show them the
airplane
oh
I showed them telephone networking and
these things
this is too much the internet I'll show
them the internet
[Music]
yeah
forget about a thousand four hundred
years ago
yeah I need 500 years ago 300 years ago
people would be shocked in fact I mean
I'm not sure does anyone know how the
the airplane was invented
I mean they say the Wright brothers
right you know the Wright brothers in
1907 I think it was 19. apparently it
should be 1907. there was two American
guys yes
there's different claimants you see like
for example in Brazil they have this
very important figure who has a I would
say a stronger claim I forget his name
now to who invented the airplane yeah
anyway the point is this is that when it
first came out and he was starting to
ride it in Paris
people were accusing him of all kinds of
stuff that was in 1907 or something like
that
because they were completely they were
making a democracy of it if you look at
the newspaper articles they were making
a mockery he said this guy believes he
can fly around the air
that's what they were saying
now you see why this is relevant it's a
hundred years ago
where the woman didn't even have the
vote in the country
they didn't until 1914
but they had the labor party they had
this they had that they had the
conservatives there in America they had
the Democrats they had the Republicans
things were in place they had the
Constitution and they were they were
shocked
and bewildered at the fact that there
were airplanes they were making fun of
that as a fact
why because today's technology is
yesterday's magic everything is
incredulous to everybody
until it's seen
what is so difficult about believing in
a creature with 600 rings
oh yeah honey nowadays we live in an age
where these guys are showing me the
neural link something you put in
someone's head and then you can get them
information from their brain and you can
load your information they say yeah you
can load it
and they say you can put the meta first
they put the goggles and they're in some
other place
but they're in their mom's backyard but
actually now they're in Times Square
what I'm saying is now with the age of
Technology
we should be the most capable of
believing the ribiet of any humans in
any time in history because we've seen
it being proven so many times
where's the Allah is where is The
Logical contradiction so long as there's
no logical contradiction
there should be no problem
but you know what
in I would say
you'd be very surprised at what people
believe scientists materialists atheists
have you heard of The Double Split
Split For example I'm not going to go
into details but let me on the quantum
level they say one particle can be in
two places at the same time
you know Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone well let's go
I remember when he ran through the wall
people say this is impossible but in the
quantum world this is possible
you can run through walls and you can be
in two players at the same time
okay I'll put it in this way for you
yeah
if I were to take
a quantum physics textbook
and instead of using the terms the
scientific terms I'll use religious
terms
the whole thing becomes what they would
call a fairy tale
immediately
but a fairy tale of the fact of the
white man with the lab coat says it
that's their profit of the day
no one has seen this particle in two
places at the same time
and by the way they can't see it the
quantum world is invisible
I just just to let you know it
oh look you guys believe Richard talk
and say you believe in Barack it goes
here it goes there you believe in Wings
the animal donkey this whatever
say donkey's so much easier to believe
than a particle one particle be in two
places at the same time because that's a
logical contradiction
and if you don't want to believe in
those things
that is true isn't it
it's true
so the ripe is the easiest thing to
believe in today
I don't believe in these things it's my
friend but then when he goes to the
scientists
and they tell him
an evolutionary theory that basically
I'm being vague here or I'm being crude
that a well-like creature became a
cow-like creature
it's in the same family according to the
classifications a whale became a cow how
did it just jump on the air no it had to
make so many Transformations did we see
those Transformations no we didn't but
we wouldn't believe it because the white
man with the lab coat said it
he's colonized our minds
he's told us what fairy tales to believe
in
he's given it the label of approval he
said this is the one
but we don't even know this guy's
history the lab code okay
we don't even know what he's what he's
been doing
we don't know what collaboration is part
of what pharmaceutical company all those
things that we were doing a damn of the
prophets we don't do it to him of these
guys with
what what Financial incentives does he
have you don't think scientists have
Financial incentives
the pharmaceutical companies and so they
they are open we want to maximize our
profits
Eugenics they were saying the black man
is less than the white man
and they were using science
even Charles Charles Darwin he says that
the black man has a Fifth Third
he had like a thumb on his foot he
didn't even know these things he said
he's a Savage
and then this Hitler and those guys they
use the Eugenics programs what I'm
saying to you is this
science can be misappropriated can be
used it can be weaponized
so the reason why I preambled because a
lot of this discussion is about ripe
about Allah taking the prophet sallam to
a certain place
and this place in that place and he saw
this and that so I can't believe in any
of it I haven't seen it
yeah but in that case let's reject
almost all of science
let's see how the the materialists in
the dinner table feels like when he
rejects quantum mechanics